[Música]
sabían que existen carreras en los
cuales los competidores van mucho más
allá de los cuarenta y dos famosos
kilómetros que tienen una maratón
concretamente carreras de 70 80 100 120
160 y hasta demás kilómetros lo sabían
bueno te cuento estas carreras se llama
ultramaratones pero si adicionalmente
por donde se corren es por la montaña sí
señores por la montaña saltando piedras
cruzando el río subiendo y bajando a
estas particularmente se las denomina
carreras de ultra trade
seguida inevitablemente surge la
pregunta porque corren
para que corren que de pase estos pibes
en qué momento se golpearon la cabeza
para agregarse a correr
arriba de la montaña sí
saltando bajando está saltando entre
piedras a veces con temperaturas abajo
de cero a veces arriba de los 30 grados
a veces bajo la lluvia a veces en la
altura con falta de oxígeno y hasta a
veces saltando alemanias en medio de la
célula que te hicieron tus viejos cuando
era chico por dios denunciado ya ya
mi nombre sebastián tengo 47 años soy
papá de mirando de salvador estoy casado
con candelas de hace 17 años
casi 18 si trabajo a tiempo completo
como la mayoría de ustedes y soy el
corredor de ultra trail pero sobre todas
las cosas y para definirme en un todo a
partir de cómo elegir transitar la vida
puedo decirles que soy un tipo
apasionado
esta sociedad moderna a la cual
pertenecemos si vive por decirlo de
alguna forma una vida carente de
desafíos por eso quien se inicia esta
actividad en una primera instancia busca
simplemente eso el desafío en sí pero a
medida que la práctica se hace hábito el
desafío por cumplir se le suma la
necesidad de la práctica en sí mismo
porque al correr conectamos con un
instinto primitivo correr es una
conexión ancestral con nuestra esencia
básica corríamos para cazar corríamos
para migrar cuando las condiciones no
eran las indicadas porque el clima
golpeaba corríamos para escapar los
depredadores si la evolución fue
perfeccionando nuestro diseño hasta
transformarlos en corredores naturales
si el cuerpo humano presenta una serie
de particularidades que nos diferencian
en otras especies y que en resumen en
nosotros uno de los cuerpos más
eficientes del reino animal
una vez llegada a la hora de la hora de
correr todo esto era fundamental en
nuestros primeros pasos por la sabana
momento en el momento en el cual es para
sobrevivir y para él y mente para
alimentarnos teníamos por ejemplo que
perseguir una presa hasta que ésta
cayera extenuada sabiendo en una primera
instancia que la misma por velocidad nos
iba a ganar pero incapaz de mantener un
ritmo sostenido durante mucho tiempo
bueno por suerte y gracias a dios no
tenemos que andar corriendo le carreras
a los antílopes para cenar ni a los
leones para evitar cercenados si
evolucionamos
nuestra hipotética evolución nos ha
separado una distancia astronómica de la
real necesidad la necesidad moderna no
tiene absolutamente nada que ver con la
definición de necesidad básica hablo de
lo que quiero deseo diciendo necesito
cuando en realidad en la mayoría de las
oportunidades de lo que hablo son de
cuestiones materiales cosas que cargo en
mi mochila y no hacen otra cosa que
dificultar mi carrera y vuelve cuando
corres un ultra que vamos a pasar
corriendo 8 10 15 20 horas y hasta en
ocasiones hasta más de un día te puedo
asegurar que si algo que no quieres
llevar peso extra y yo solamente lo
necesario para hidratarte para
alimentarte para abrigarse para cuidarte
y nada más y así es liviano tan liviano
como llegamos y tan livianos como nos
vamos a ir porque si bien reconozco que
en este mensaje
hay mucho para entenderse como una
apología pro running si reloj que me
pasó con esta actividad es que me
encontré logre que reconfigurar me y
entendí que la vida es un combo de bueno
de malo de lindo de feo de zinc y de
yang y que no sirve de nada ver el vaso
medio lleno si no estoy dispuesto a
tomar lo bueno ese vaso es la pasión y
se llena con todo lo que hace una vida y
yo quiero hasta la última gota de ese
vaso porque ese agua que hay en ese vaso
no se la puedo dejar a nadie o la tomo o
se pierde y entonces si siendo líbano
aborde mi pasión
solamente me tengo que preocupar por lo
que siento por lo que me pasa por lo que
es lo que mis sentidos pueden percibir y
así entonces durante todo este tiempo
transitar por infinidad de estadios
excitación y ansiedad euforia alegrías
momentos de duda abatimiento soledad una
palabra de sensaciones sentimientos y
pensamientos que no hacen otra cosa que
es venir a esta experiencia como única y
realmente difícil
en palabras pero momento a ver estoy
hablando de una carrera de ultra estoy
hablando de la vida
sin dudas la primera es una suerte de
metáfora resumida de la vida misma que
no solamente demuestra cómo es tu
actitud frente a las diferentes
situaciones sino que te forma y te
prepara para enfrentar con claridad esa
diaria que a veces abruma y no te deja
ver el bosque porque yo hoy encontré mi
pasión si soy el dijo correr porque el
corre con el cuerpo puede mi cabeza
volar porque puedo sentir literalmente
mi corazón bombeando sangre a través de
mis venas porque al correr puedo abrir
mis sentidos y sentir el mundo pegándome
en la cara muy distinto como corría
antes por porque si corría corría pero
ciego mundo de color a un mundo que me
gritaba mientras iba solo dominando el
celular corría con la cabeza porque era
incapaz de enseñarle a volar hasta que
salí
allá afuera me resistí a sucumbir al
extravío del sillón y la serie y salí
quería jugar a bailar a reinventar un
mundo inventado pero con cada vez más
locos más locos que lo habitan
y así no sucumbir como bien les decía
entonces redefinir
estas situaciones a las cuales yo me
estaba
dejando llevar así entonces me subí a mi
pasión
y videntes y vivir la vida como un fin
entendiendo que para vivirla como un fin
hay un montón de medios necesarios pero
que son simplemente esos medios que la
vida está mucho más allá de eso es ese
norte al cual tengo que llegar por más
que el camino tenga muchos retomes giros
y curvas y así estas experiencias a las
cuales la pasión me lleve esa que elegí
para tomar hasta la última gota que
tiene mi vaso deja te dejan de ser
físicas o mentales y pasan a ser
espirituales y si es que existe un ir
bala es exactamente ese momento en el
cual me conecto con mi pasión el mismo
momento en el cual entiendo en el cual
me convenzo que el paraíso no es un
lugar el paraíso es un estado
y que no importa realmente tanto si
cambio el auto no lo cambio mi casa
tienen suficientes cuartos sí y que no
importa si es mi ego es alquilada que
mis hijos no necesitan la mejor de las
educaciones y eso les cuesta el tiempo
que demanda un abrazo que mi felicidad
necesita una vida para poder existir y
esa vida necesita un tiempo para poder
ser vivida porque mañana mañana si
mañana macho mañana mujer mañana nos
vamos a morir
y solo nos quedan las anécdotas del
viaje
entonces cuando lo ves
las prioridades cambian el tiempo se
transforma
respirar miras escuchar sentís pero de
verdad abrazar reír by las bolas jugar
si haces momentos sublimes en el cual
soy uno con la tierra con el cielo con
la montaña con la ciudad con el
mismísimo cosmos con tu dios sea cual
fuere si con todos y con cada uno y todo
en un mismo sentimiento
sin perfecta no hay pensamientos solo un
mantra hecho movimiento y es en ese
momento en el que yo viviendo mi pasión
siento que puedo correr para siempre
porque si yo corro yo vuelo y volando
llego a mis sueños a esos mismos sueños
que siendo chico soñaba seguido pero que
los años las presiones y esta forma de
vivir a la cual nos empujaron se
encargaron de enterrar muy abajo pero
ese motor que es la pasión no para de
amplificar su potencia una vez que lo
enciendes si no solamente te orienta te
alienta y te guía en eso en eso donde
nace en eso que supiste encontrar en eso
que no vas a poder dejar nunca jamás
sino que es muy ambiciosa y cada vez
quiere más entonces se meten toda tu
vida y contagia a los demás
transformándose en ese vehículo que nos
lleve directo y sin escalas ese tan
preciado estado transformado en palabra
ni más ni menos que la felicidad
pero es necesario bucear porque la
pasión no vive en la superficie entonces
tenemos que explorar en nuestro interior
y entender qué es lo que realmente nos
apasiona y una vez que lo encontramos a
jugarse a seguir esa dirección aunque en
este ni cerca del camino por el cual
venimos transitando porque la vía es eso
es cambio
es tiempo el tiempo no vuelve y el
tiempo no para él sea la bersuit son una
chance sí y entender que el balance
siempre va a ser bueno porque lo malo
solamente puede definirse si existe lo
bueno y los colores del cielo un día que
se muere son los mismos colores del
cielo de un día que nace y así dejar que
el espacio nos lleve para que aparezcan
las preguntas por qué
para qué
quien lo que más me gusta hacer es eso
que necesito sentir que es lo que mueve
el motor de mi vida el de mi vida sin
miedo a caer a un pensamiento peor y
egoísta porque no lo es es vital está
primario cuál es el combustible de mi
motor
y el tuyo
lo sabemos
la respuesta es no
a buscar y si lo encontramos jugar sería
cambiar porque cambiar no sólo te cambia
vos contagiadas por ahora somos pocos
pero muchos pocos son un muchísimo así
que arranca arranca
recuerden que el paraíso no es un lugar
el paraíso es un estado así que a
levantarse y a correr hacia el lugar
donde queremos ir no importa el lugar
del camino en el cual nos encontremos
hoy no es tarde mañana así que la vida
la vida pasa demasiado rápido como para
no vivirla
[Aplausos]